how are you seeing we were high patent
we were just as funny as you walked in
we were just talking about real light
stuff yeah no we were just talking about
in Las Vegas and now now this conspiracy
theories about it and I'm just amazed at
how some conspiracy theories catch like
how do they catch on I don't know how
people listen to them and go like oh
yeah that makes sense
well has this way I hang on what is just
let you like a little bit Oh what is the
conspiracy theory and has this caught on
what's the newest one what's going on
choice good choice guys they're saying
that if I and tell me if I'm wrong Troy
that uh there was multiple shooters that
Isis is involved and it's just
speculated that Isis could be involved
and this is being covered up but for
unknown reasons why it would be covered
up but as I was saying before again it's
like politics you're either on this side
or you're on that side you nobody can
ever say yes I believe the official
story of this I believe this is what
happened I believe what's been told is
really the way it went down but I saw
this piece of evidence that's a little
weird I'm still believe what has been
told to me but ah look at that that's a
little strange
is that what you're saying I'm just
saying when you use heat is that what
you're saying right now what I'm telling
you is I believe the story of what we're
told but there's evidence that there
could possibly be a second shooter all
right my new Netflix special what's your
special
it's called annihilation perfect you
know can I just say something that
conspiracy theory and I'm not saying
this to insult you or anything but it
just seems to me that it's actually very
terrifying to think that random awful
things can happen for no reason and
every conspiracy theory if you notice
they always involve oh no there was a
huge plan in place it's a multiple P in
other words it's that they're trying to
put the illusion of there are even if
the people are evil but there are people
in control with a plan rather than know
some weird nut ball went up in a book
depository with a cheap rifle and killed
the president no no that can't be it
safer to think of it exactly that even
if it's evil there is some competitive
chaos because then I can see it coming
I'm an agent of chaos Jim Norton agent
anyway what is chaos percentage-wise
[Laughter]
yeah I mean 9/11 this you know the new
people cannot it's terrifying to think
that people aren't in control and yeah
and you're right and you're right
because nobody we've never been lied to
ever about anything it's just that it's
crazy to me that just you can't look at
something be like that's a little weird
not saying it's we everything all the
craziness is is true but look at
something be like yeah that's that I
don't think that's what he was saying
though like I I know what you why you're
saying that but I that's I feel that
saying my patent does about conspiracy
and it's not that like you're being
naive in thinking the government doesn't
lie it's just the point of why do people
argue parts of conspiracy that seem
really irrational to me and I do feel
it's a safer and more palatable thing
that there's a big agency if anything
the the government lies after the fact
after they've let chaos slip through and
then they will lie to give you the
illusion that there was some kind of
order right but as far as I'm sorry like
multiple people keeping quiet about
something that he I just I don't buy it
I just I especially now especially in
2017 nothing there's I just don't buy it
that's his name couldn't even call the
president a [ __ ] [ __ ] without
everybody yeah this is like we're
finding out stuff nowadays that it you
should take all the principles had to be
dead and then Robert Caro had to
research her from there ten years yeah
to get like oh yeah LBJ used to
interview people while taking a [ __ ]
people would know immediately yeah they
would be immediately Trump was ticketed
would be a tweet of his login he's not a
vegan it's hard to do you think any job
because you're very political a guy and
people know where you stand politically
dude does it ever get like he's like
sometimes you have like I just want to
talk about [ __ ] I just want to be
silly yeah you're tired
fending Trump I hold on a second look
the guy you know it's actually and I
talk about this in my special everyone
that says I get so pissed off right now
when people say you comedians must be so
happy having Trump as president I'm like
okay for one thing at best like when
Bush was president I got 10 minutes of
material out of that and I would have
happily traded that away if we weren't
torturing people and our money wasn't on
fire and with Trump it's the same thing
we're at best
I'll get 10 minutes out of it in the
long run Trump is so exhausting where
and I do this bit about how writing a
Trump joke it is instantly stale because
whatever you've made fun of an hour
later he will do something crazier and
people will even forget what you just
you know I mean yeah I challenge you to
say that when you're watching my thing
about some day the president's gonna go
you fired but I like making fun of Trump
doing a Trump joke is like imagine that
was a crazy guy on the sidewalk and he
just takes a dump on the sidewalk right
and you turn to your friends and you
have the funniest joke about him taking
that dump and as you turn to tell your
friends a joke behind you he takes the
the [ __ ] and makes like a sombrero out
of it and then you tell your dumb joke
they go oh dude Turney he just made us
some you're out of touch yeah you could
look back you know I don't have a joke
for this yeah why do you think this
fascinates me too like you're really
liberal James Ford really conservative
what is it about this thing where if
somebody is tweeting or coming from a
point of view that's not ours we [ __ ]
hate them like when did it become so
like split down the middle like people
who because you're a funny comic and
then there's people who will hate you
because of your opinions they'll hate
this one because of his conservative
opinions they don't hate Nick DiPaolo
who's brilliant yeah I think right now a
people are in such kind of dire straits
financially and socially and and just
you know there's just there's people
there's huge chunks of the population
out there they're just living with no
hope and so they will get behind
something a a team or whatever city
there
they're constantly just being insulted
and put down so if this is this if
there's somebody like a trump who even
if he's openly not helping them but if
he says things that makes them feel
better they will latch on to that and
then get very very offended when people
and then on people that were against
Trump that were that we're being
insulted by him whoever they latch on to
then they get angry if anyone says
anything pot so I mean we're just the
country is in a bad place right now and
and this is nothing new if there's a
great book by Rick pearl scene called
Nixon land this same [ __ ] was going down
in the early 70s where people would feel
like friendships died because of you
know someone voted Nixon and someone in
May like I can't talk to you because
people were so frightened yeah and
people get so so quickly and you look at
what's happening even now with Hollywood
with with Harvey Weinstein and the way
like people like get coming I come oh my
god you knew it's like all we do is just
stand there and point fingers at each
other what do you think it is about
because he's a powerful dude man and he
well do you think it was no he's not
anymore no now is probably the time
he'll decide that he likes me
did you is it that people are afraid of
having their careers ruined or we
speculated the lot of times people just
don't know exactly what's true and don't
want to publicly accuse if they don't
know exactly what's true I mean I'm sure
it's a combination of all of them people
forget how frightening it can be if
you're in the creative arts and and
people can put people in power can put
pressure on you where they will destroy
your career if you stand up or you speak
a little bit look what happened to Rose
McGowan she was ten years early on this
totally speaking the truth totally you
know now you know she's a hero but she
went through she got put through the
Thresher for this they just blocked her
on Twitter they they but as someone
pointed out yeah she just got blocked
for insulting Ben Affleck oh hang on let
me head over to Richard Spencer's feed
and look at the info on the newest Klan
rally like it's it's actually I would
like that I tried to get they sending
them to followers but we're don't like
all of a sudden this one's blah I can I
read the tweets like what did she say
that she says something libelous she
just said that you're lying cuz you knew
[ __ ] off Ben Affleck like [ __ ] oh like
that's the mild insult
I know I've written far if that gets her
suspended I shouldn't be allowed to have
a computer for this right so you know
you know I it also just went what what
bothers me is when let's say there's
some issue like um you know I do a lot
of work with veterans and veterans
rights and benefits and you know trying
to get them stuff and if you so if you
but if you speak out on any issue
somebody will also go well what about
this stuff in like they'll wear like I
can't comment on everything just assume
if I'm trying to help this group out I'm
also sympathetic for the other group but
I don't I only have so much
signal-to-noise to spread around so like
I what you're doing - but let me just
support you don't I mean like if you're
helping animals think how come you don't
like kids yeah exactly yeah but and and
if if I if I tweet or signal boost
everything then none of it gets helped
because it's too much so I try to focus
and pick you know the the the Harvey
Weinstein thing was hit me particularly
because I know a lot of actresses that
that have gone through this should not
even necessarily with Harvey but just in
the industry that I've seen it over the
years and also people will go why didn't
you say anything [ __ ] ten years ago
cuz I was nobody and and I couldn't do
it there was nothing I could do about it
now that I have a platform and a voice
[ __ ] yeah I'm gonna use it and when it's
out there and you know that when
multiple people are confirming it
happened to them but it is weird when
it's just like rumor and like so it's
like I never heard anything about that
you know that's not a show business I am
I literally had no idea Harvey Weinstein
was trying to [ __ ] everybody I had no
idea I also had that's before you came
in like I don't think it's about like
attacking like the Seth MacFarlane's or
whatever the world that were like well
if you knew three years ago you should
set some three years ago it's about the
companies themselves that set up spaces
where people could act because the
companies are the ones that could have
actually done something about it and
actually those are the people that had
the power the CEOs and and and the
people who were in the Harvey Weinstein
bracket some of whom are probably still
doing this stuff
that the the that could have said
something because Harvey wasn't gonna
destroy their careers and live like I
was pointing out how it must be imagined
being actually I can't I can't do this I
can't imagine I'm not gonna insult
people by going I can totally I can't I
can't imagine being a woman in 2017
watching Harvey Weinstein go down in
flames the way he is right now
deservedly so yeah and but then
flashback to a year earlier the exact
same [ __ ] came out about Trump and he's
in the White House like you know how
[ __ ] surreal but were they're
terrifying that must feel it was it was
a little bit different with were there
FEMA with their women who actually
accused Trump of doing things besides
like 17 accusers step forward and talked
about inappropriate gropings
inappropriate um you know barging in
while they're dressing and oops haha
like laughing about it all that 17
there's that's amazing how all these
Magdalene Linna like where where are the
accuser there's literally 17 I can't
google it it's right there but but what
bothers me is when I then point that out
to go why didn't I never hear you saying
anything about Clinton I'm like well
know in the 90s when I was doing
stand-up I was ripping into Bill Clinton
for what he did to Monica no one ever
heard of it because I was [ __ ]
featuring it cranberries yeah I've
always been speaking out but I didn't
have the platform then so what the [ __ ]
you get the platform and you're like hey
I now want to make my point of views
clear on everything in my entire life
now that there are people listening
here's what I say today here's what I
was saying five years this was ten years
ago when I was in third grade I thought
you know there's probably very little I
can do about ex-president Bill Clinton
at this point but right now president
yeah there's maybe something we can do
and I'm gonna do it when I can so it but
again that that just goes what we're
talking earlier people will defend their
peepees sticks yeah for their side of
the art it's it's a weird thing we do
and did if I remember correctly get some
[ __ ] for his behavior yes he does Museum
Oh impeached no he got quite a lot of
[ __ ] but what they're saying is when
they point
your hip where was your sling no no I
was I just wasn't famous you didn't know
who the [ __ ] I was I'm the opposite I
defend both of them so and you're
getting by the like you're out you're
getting married in November how does it
feel it feels November November 4th ok
it feels amazing
it feels surreal to go from that level
of despair to this level of joy like I
have these I have these worries where
what if I'm a glass that you put in the
freezer yeah overnight and then you just
put hot water and it just explode like
it's too much right of both extremes but
yeah motion for one light it's way too
much is it hard to because I've never
been through either experience is it
hard to now that you're getting married
and you feel this joy do you is there a
part of you in the back because you know
that you didn't leave somebody is there
a part of you in the back that feels
like I'm not supposed to be feeling this
joy you know yeah I I always that always
comes up and I've talked to other
friends of mine who were widowers and
also in this grief support group that
I'm in and and they're like just because
you know there's there's people that I I
went out with in high school that I
still remember the good times for them
and then I remember being in love but
but that's not now so I had 13 amazing
years with Michelle I'll always remember
that I'll always love it like I talked
to my new fiance Meredith about it when
we go on a hike she goes you still miss
her right I'm like absolutely I always
will but she's not here she's you know
she's not here you're here and you're
amazing and and the kind of person that
that Michelle helped me to become is
what helped me meet and and become
friends and in love with somebody like
Meredith
I mean it wouldn't have happened if I'd
never met Michelle and what Meredith is
doing it's like that's crazy strong cuz
they have the the kind of I don't know
if it's the word is confidence but to
not be made to feel insecure exudes I'll
bet because like you said it didn't end
bad so it's not like you're just
remembering the good times and that's
what it like which is good times like it
would yes they'll be in that really
exactly and she and but but she again
Meredith is beyond strong she's like one
of those elevated people that you meet
we're like oh that's a level of wisdom
and humility that I kind of need to get
to right things I think that
the next level so and you know she ends
up talking me through things that I
almost feel like I should be talking her
through sometimes she goes no no so you
got to do this and there's like and the
fact that she's like I'm stepping up to
not just be a wife but to be a mom to be
a mom to this little girl like and she's
got a 12 inch tall she's eight whoo I
guess I got like even if I guess eight
we're gonna guess and he was like wow
and you know obviously you go to this
horrible Greek period how long after is
it when you're like okay I have to move
forward well it was I mean there were
months when it wasn't even that I was in
grief that I was in I don't even know if
I'm alive that was the scariest part
where there were days when I would get
up I'm like what if I'm the one who's
actually dead and it was so horrifying
to have my body dying then that you know
like that thing where you can imagine a
whole other life in the last second
before your brain dies but you're
actually dying yeah there's that theory
and I was like what if I'm imagining
this right now because I can't deal with
a body horror of my organs shutting down
so I've imagined that the next worst
scenario which is losing Michelle and
Evan my but all of this is fake right
and this none of this is happening but
it wasn't until she passed away in April
of 2016 I don't think I was really able
to start functioning until late August
of that year and then I didn't even meet
I didn't even meet Meredith and I here's
how Meredith and I met we have mutual
friends on Facebook we'd never spoken on
Facebook for some reason we were
following each other I think thing cuz
we had all these same friends follow you
know who you are you knew who I exactly
yeah
but we never spoke so we got invited to
a dinner party together on February 28th
we're mutual friends with that actress
Martha Plimpton
we're friend yeah so she goes and she
was having random friends over and the
last minute I couldn't go because of
travel or something so the next day
Meredith sent me a face
message saying oh you missed some
amazing lasagna last night you really
screwed up you know and then I wrote
about shoot we'll go out and get listen
whatever like some jokey thing and then
we just started talking every single
night on Facebook for hours like writing
short novels basically back and forth
every like same time tomorrow night same
time tomorrow night February 28th until
May 20 we did not meet face to face or
even speak until May 20th it was just
three writing three months three months
which does force you in a way to get to
know somebody because no your honor you
can't just sit there and watch TV you
actually have to communicate exactly
what our moments to Stephen King he's
really heard a book about something
about a woman dying and he said that the
husband freaked out when he looked at
the book she had been reading and he
realized she'd never read the next page
yeah what are moments that you have that
are like oh my god the the moments with
me for Michelle are you know cuz she was
writing a book yes she was researching
this um so whenever I would see new
updates about this cold case that she
had helped get the case reopened and
then some new revelation come out she's
not here to to parse this out or to go
okay we should fall open this or not
they were all so certain I remember I
remember very distinctly when I watch
there's a show called the night of it's
an HBO oh yeah sure crime show with them
John Turturro intro is amazing with the
lead actor he was in rogue one a young
lion Stu one of the Mars comedy was a
masterpiece
yeah he's incredible he's incredible in
that show but it's about police
procedural and it's since Richard Price
wrote it it's very very true to life and
I remember watching the last episode
when the first time ever I saw your face
is playing and you realize that - Turo
has adopted that cat even though it's it
he's allergic to it but he wants to save
it and the combination of oh my god she
would have loved this show and she would
have been able to go sit there and watch
true crime stuff you should go no that
doesn't no that's wrong right that's oh
my god I can't believe they just got
that right
you know we watched making a murderer
together and she was like that cop needs
to be fired that holds interrogation
like did she comment that you look like
Steven Avery
[Laughter]
I remember I remember distinctly talking
to her because I was listening to you
talk about making a murderer and then I
came home I was like I was a Jim Norton
was talking about making a murderer she
goes yeah he goes I go it all go down
too because you talked about all the
stuff all the doubts and then I go but
basically Steve Avery is a boob but I
just remember I was at the end of the
night of I really started crying because
I'm like I never got to sit and why and
hear her talk about this and hear her
experiences and I was just like
something as minor as like a TV show or
then like when my wouldn't when our
daughter got her ears pierced I took I
took Alice to get her ears pierced and
then when when Alice was out of sight
didn't see me I just started bawling
like aw she should have been there for
that you know there's all these to me
all these little parenting moments she
won't get to do so you get yourself to
not cry in front of your daughter like
how do you sorry I I find a million
excuses to go Oh daddy's gotta go take
this call and I'll go somewhere and just
you know and I can I've learned to do
that very quiet like it's almost like
the way you sneeze but you hold it in
right you cry but it it is all like you
get you get that you get that push of
weeping out of yourself without really
you know but there's been some there's
been some rough times and is that stuff
still like popping up now meaning like
as you're now getting married again like
that's going to come up and and this is
just part of life now I don't I mean you
know I talked to I had friends who got
married like nine months after their
spouse died and they were like you know
you your body wants to heal itself and
it will find a way to turn the grief
into what an amazing person I got to be
with yeah and this new person is in
credit and you will just experience joy
it really doesn't and I I don't want to
sound callous it doesn't come up it
certainly doesn't come up from me
feeling wise whenever I'm with Meredith
right and it certainly doesn't come up
when when it's me and Meredith and Alice
hanging out cuz
is so happy that I'm just like I'm just
gonna run with this you know cuz I don't
want my daughter to remember these fun
years of her dad sitting there brooding
and trying to avoid her I don't want to
give that to her sure anyway and it was
something that was on your end
unavoidable like it wasn't like oh I
could have done this or that you
understand you have finality because you
didn't do anything that you shouldn't
have done and also you start thinking of
as awful as it was and this is another
coping mechanism and you feel really
sick doing this but it is a coping
mechanism where you're like this could
have happened like this happened while
Alice was at school she'd already you
know I'd already taken her to school
Alice could have could have discovered
her dead or or Michelle could have been
driving her to school and then like
there's a million yes.we worse and you
will do that and I remember when I was
in the grief group going I can't believe
I'm running these scenarios to my head
like no no you're supposed to yeah that
sounds normal like and so obviously it
was you you had come home or did you
wake up and discover her I got up super
early um Michelle was you know writing
on this big deadline and she had not
been getting a lot of sleep and I was
like you know you sleep in and and I got
up and I remember very to saying that
she was snoring really last Mike oh good
she's asleep
good she's getting she's catching up on
her sleep went god Alice you know got
her breakfast got her dressed backpack
went to school you know talked to her
teachers came back I stopped at
Starbucks I got Michelle Grande
americano
she lived in americano put that on her
on the table by the bed went back
upstairs like now it's like 9:30 she's
still snoring went up to my office
I had calls to make I had some writing
to do I saw that prince had died
commenting on that on Twitter for a
little bit at 2:00 o'clock that day
Alice had an art show at school that we
were gonna then attend so at 12:00 I
don't know why I remember this so
specifically 12:42 p.m. I went down to
go hey you know what in case you're
still see I figured she be awake already
but we're gonna leave at 1:15 and that's
when I discovered her do you let me ask
you said she was snoring was it was it
obviously I do you think she died of
sleep apnea I don't mean there was an
undiagnosed heart thing and then
she was also taking way more
prescription meds than she should have
been because she was having trouble
sleeping and you know that stuff can
feed itself it will slow that's what
that's what that when I was talking to
the corner like yeah this stuff can
build up in your system and really and
that's what it's not like you take the
one overdose it builds up over time so I
don't know about sleep apnea because she
didn't like wake up in the middle of the
night a lot but but there was definitely
a heart thing that was that was and it
was a thing that you which I found out
later has a very very long name my tocar
it was a long thing but it's a thing
that you cannot detect unless you were
very specifically looking for it with a
battery of tests like it doesn't just
show up so it's just it really sucked
yeah there was no way to prevent it
and I only asked about the app because
snoring is when your tongue is blocking
your air yeah that's why you do it you
don't you wear a CPAP man no I just fall
but it's a long story because you're
scared well that's the only reason
anybody asks anything cuz we're so it
affects us yeah you know I was checking
for it but the app it's hard to do it
but they say like you know there are
people that die of it but anyway I'm
really sorry man and you know I'm happy
for you that you've that you're at least
your living and your yeah you know
you're gonna continue living you know
and you should be happy not not about
that but you you should continue your
life happy
well you have to I have a daughter I
don't want to you know I can't I can't
not continue right I can't that's
probably really good it is no I've said
if I didn't have Alice I would just be I
would happily be a shut-in alcoholic and
just be done with everything right and
we just kind of and would let myself die
you don't have the choice I don't have a
choice yeah there's there's a really
dark funny line in a little movie called
the anniversary party with Phoebe Cates
as in and it was I came out in the early
aughts Alan [ __ ] and Jennifer Jason
Leigh but phoebe cates who she kind of
retired from acting because she's a mom
but she's cries she goes having children
it just removes suicide as an option
like there's something so dark and funny
about thank God I don't have kids
the whole message getting guy